SPEAKER 1: I run this team of--
I like to think of them
as persuasion scientists--
at "The Wall Street Journal,"
at Dow Jones more broadly.
And if you go to wsj.com,
or you go to our apps,
if you go to barrons.com, if
you go to the "Barron's" apps,
you're probably in an
experiment that we're running.
And I've been doing this
for about three years now.
The team started
with about two of us.
Now we're up to five.
We're hiring a couple
more people next year.
It's obviously just
been really fun.
Testing is-- if you're unsure of
it-- testing is really, really
fun.
It's extremely validating.
You just get this
immediate gratification
and there's just this
beautiful customer feedback
loop that you're
basically just trying
to harness and interpret.
So where do we test?
And what do we test for?
Back in 2015, the
subscription business
essentially went through
a digital transformation.
They said, we need to
kind of rejigger things
and set ourselves up
for more digital growth.
And so there are a
number of changes.
One of them was that they
made this little team.
And they said, here's some
money and go do some testing.
And that's about all
the guidance we had
and that's about all we needed.
But the best place to start any
testing experimentation program
is on the acquisition side.
It's really difficult
to screw up your results
or to not figure out when
you did something good.
More orders, more money
is usually a good thing.
So we spent more than
a year just focused
on solving for acquisition.
But of course, then we
realized testing is something
that all you really need is
you need a digital moment.
You need lots of traffic.
And you need to know what
you want people to do.
So you could basically apply
it to any digital experience
as long as you've got all
those things lined up.
So we moved up the funnel
onto the editorial site,
but for people who
were unsubscribed.
So trying to change that
experience and optimize that
experience so we could
increase the conversion
rate from content.
And then also moving
down the funnel
where obviously all of you
guys are extremely well
aware that onboarding is a
critical moment where you can
really sort of set up
your members, your users,
for success or for failure.
And again, we've pushed
out again in 2018.
We've partnered with the
core product team, which
is sort of the stewards of just
what it means to consume "Wall
Street Journal" content.
So we're solving just for real
kind of true product KPIs.
We're going to add some more--
we're teaming up with
the retention team.
We're teaming up with
the education team.
So we're just kind of
getting our tendrils out
across the business, where there
is sort of the stakeholder, who
has the real ownership of the
real estate or the business
outcome.
And we try to facilitate
them achieving that by--
because we become experts at the
discipline of experimentation.
Another way to look at it
is you look at the metrics
that we're actually solving for.
They've obviously exploded.
So how do we choose
what to test?
Now I don't know--
in this room, would you guys--
who here isn't doing any
AB multivariate testing?
Great.
Who feels like they're
just starting out?
OK.
So we're in-- we're
further along the curve.
Regardless of where you
are, these three slides,
I think, are the most important
slides in terms of, I think,
driving the success
that we've seen.
The first thing is that we--
three years in-- we are
still obsessively hunting
the low-hanging fruit.
There is this thing that happens
where once businesses become
committed to making
data-driven decisions,
they often over-rotate
towards making things
really complicated and
really fancy really soon,
because if it's fancier
and it's more complicated
and it seems harder,
it seems better.
But in fact, business
is difficult.
So any time things
are easy, you want
to hold on for all it's worth.
And I think there's been
this sort of misconception
where the active segmenting
and personalizing experiences,
that's what represents the
biggest upside when it comes
to experimentation
and just manipulating
digital experiences, when
in fact, what we've found
is that the "one size fits all"
learnings-- basic navigation,
basic design, evergreen
copy that always wins,
that's the low-hanging fruit
that's sitting right there.
And that actually represents,
at minimum, 50% of the upside.
Whereas things like
segment-based experiences,
all of those have to
work a lot harder, right?
So for example, in
my case, if I have
some theory about how I
could speak to people coming
from opinion content and
I run a test, a 10% uplift
on just people coming
from opinion traffic
has got to work 10 times as
hard as a 10% uplift that
applies to every man, woman, and
child who's considering buying
"The Wall Street Journal."
So that really has, I think,
been a pretty important driver
of our success.
And then you've got
personalization up here.
Again, there's plenty
of upside there,
but just if you skip
out on this stuff,
you're just making it
harder on yourself.
And as I said, we've been
doing this for three years
and we're still finding
big "one size fits all,"
really stupid simple learnings.
So the second thing that I think
has really sort of informed
our strategy is best summed
up by this great quote
from van Gogh.
"Small emotions are the
great captains of our lives."
And obviously he'd be
rolling in his grave
if he knew we were talking
and using it in this context.
But he's not around, so
we're going to proceed.
[LAUGHTER]
What you're going to see--
and the test that I've
selected to show you guys,
you're going to be blown
away by the dramatic impact
these subtle, subtle
changes have had.
And I think that the
two takeaways in it
are, one, that you're
probably-- there's probably
a lot of upside just
lying in plain sight
really close at hand where you
don't have to do that much.
You don't have to
build a new feature.
You just can try to
manipulate the experience
as it is in terms of how it's
presented, so on and so forth.
And the second, it
should also give
you pause any time you
make a change that you
deem to be large and assume that
you know it's going to be good.
Because if they're sensitive
to things like this, then
anything that's
bigger than that,
they're definitely
going to be sensitive.
And you might have got it wrong.
So we try to test
absolutely everything
before it launches, regardless
of whether it's large or small.
The last thing that has been
sort of surprising to us
is I think when
you find yourself
in a less imaginative
place, testing
tends to steer itself
towards price and feature.
Now, obviously those are
big, very powerful levers,
because you're actually changing
the nature of the proposition.
But especially on the feature
side, that stuff is expensive.
What we've found is
that the vast majority
of the successes
we've had have been
making very, very simple
and very inexpensive
changes to copy and design,
which, as you can see,
is sort of the three buckets
more on the right side.
So again, this leads us
back to this instinct
where there's just a lot of
upside just in the window
dressing, and not in
the meat on the bones.
And if you can just create
value essentially out of nothing
just by how you position
the product without having
to make any improvement
to the product itself,
that's just the easiest money
you're ever going to get.
Who cares?
So how does an experimentation
team establish its own value?
Some places, you've
got product managers
who are managing sort of the
core product [? movement ?]
and also testing.
In our case, we sort of
have this standalone unit.
So we really want to
make sure everybody knows
if we're doing a good job.
So how does a testing
group establish its value?
They run a test.
So on the acquisition
side of things,
we actually recreated
the experience
of subscribing to "The
Wall Street Journal"
back when we began and AB tested
it against-- the experience
is a little bit dated, but
the experience you have today,
which is essentially the sum
total of all of our learnings.
There's a 64% conversion uplift.
And actually when you
break it out by device,
the numbers are much higher.
The reason why the blended
number drops to 64%
is that mobile traffic, the
ratio of mobile to desktop
traffic has dramatically shifted
and the conversion rate is just
significantly lower on mobile,
even though we've moved it up.
So there's nothing
wrong with that.
So I'm going to roll
into some examples.
Again, think about
low-hanging fruit.
I think there's
all these examples
are consistent in that
they are low-hanging fruit
and that they were restarted
with something relatively
subtle.
On the acquisition
side, cut the fat.
Add a little color.
Tell people what you
thought they already knew.
Time and place.
So cutting the fat.
The first thing
that we did was not
to have an idea about what
we should add to anything.
There's a great
Saint-Exupery quote,
which is, "the designer knows
he's done not when there's
anything to add,
but when there's
nothing left to take away."
So the first thing
we said is, let's not
assume we have any good ideas
about what we should add
to any of these experiences.
Let's look at what we
can cut, especially
when it comes to forms.
So this was the
checkout when we began.
It took what, about one
minute to complete it when
you went as fast you could.
We cut about 25% just of
the field you had to enter.
That's pure upside.
You didn't change the product.
You didn't do anything.
There's some heavy
lifting involved
in terms of some
back-end systems,
but you didn't have
to be particularly
imaginative to generate
value for your business
by experimenting in this way.
Adding a little color, right?
So this was the
page that you saw
when you downloaded "The Wall
Street Journal" Android app
on first open when we
began testing in it.
And it occurred to us that this
sort of "gray on gray on gray"
illustration wasn't
necessarily doing
the best job of painting the
picture of the wonders that
awaited you on the other side
of a "Wall Street Journal"
subscription.
So we just went to the
marketing department
and we said, could you give
us a colorized pack shot?
Let's not assume
we know anything.
Let's not add any copy.
Let's change one
variable a time.
There was a 110% order uplift.
So just put a little
spin on the ball.
Give it a little pop.
See what happens.
This is a really
interesting test.
So again, this is maybe
one of my favorites,
because you've got--
To the left, you've got
an article roadblock.
And on your right, you've got
the header of our shop page.
Now we've been doing
a really good job
of growing the
subscription business
in the last couple of years.
And one of the
components of that
has been sort of
a campaign based
model, where every month
there is a new look and feel.
There's a new price point.
There's a new message.
There's always a party down at
"The Wall Street Journal" store
effectively, right?
[LAUGHTER]
And it's been part
of our success.
But a couple of years in,
we started to ask ourselves,
if there's ever a product
that has perennial value,
timeless value, it's a product
like "The Wall Street Journal."
So maybe there's something
we could say in this moment
where someone's coming
from a piece of content
into a subscription
purchase decision that
could beat timely messages like
this every day of the year.
So we tried a lot
of different things.
So all these tests
for the record,
there are lots of variations.
I'm just showing
you the one that
won for the purposes of time.
But we have run lots
of tests that lose.
This is not my attempt
at a victory lap.
We run lots of tests that lose,
and then within tests that win,
there are lots of
variations that also lose.
But one of the things
we tried was we
tried to think of the
dumbest, simplest, stupidest
thing we could say
in this moment, which
feels like a huge
waste of time, right?
This is your moment.
I mean, we burned all
this marketing real estate
to tell people something which
should be patently obvious,
because they just
clicked an article
and they just got this big blue
thing that's in the way of it.
But we repeated ourselves,
or so we thought.
Continue reading your article
with a "WSJ" membership.
That was a 37% order
uplift from articles.
So just trying to come up with
the simplest customer empathy
and working back from there.
Time and place.
So for time immemorial,
"The Wall Street Journal"
has had a CTA strategy-- the
words that sit on our buttons
at every point in the
acquisition funnel that said,
join now and act now.
Now obviously, we just had
another chance to test it.
We know that an ad on social
or an article roadblock
or a shop page or
a checkout flow
are all very, very different
psychological moments.
So we started to dig
into that premise.
So this is an article roadblock.
So at that point,
what's actually happened
is they've actually
expressed no interest
in subscribing to "The Wall
Street Journal" whatsoever.
All they did was they say
they wanted to read article
and they found out that they
couldn't unless they paid us.
So we thought in this
moment, we're not actually--
we don't want implicit enjoin
or implicit enact is the effort
of filling out a form and
the pain of parting with
your hard-earned cash--
When in fact, all
you really want to do
is we want you to do
something that should be
fun, which is to window shop.
We just want you to
come in the store
and poke around, see if
something makes sense for you.
So we soften the language
to view membership options.
That was an 18% order
uplift from content.
Again, simple, simple, simple.
On the engagement side,
we also had some fun wins.
I had to cut these for time.
I also, for the record,
these timers are not working,
so I have no idea where I'm at.
Cool.
Make sure the pipes
are connected.
Again, I think one thing
we're really good at
is just taking the
same experience
and just staring at it
over and over again,
turning it on its side,
relentlessly re-analyzing and
re-imagining these moments
that we know are sort of
critical choke points,
either in the concept of
acquisition or engagement.
Make them eat their vegetables.
If there are good
things that you know--
if there are things that you
know will make people happy,
its worth trying to
force it on them--
within reason.
So when it came to the
world of engagement,
we write-- unlike
acquisitions, it's
a little bit harder to figure
out what you want anyone to do.
There's all these-- you know,
clearly doing stuff in your app
or on your website is usually
not a sign of bad engagement.
It is, by definition,
engagement.
But in our case from a
subscription perspective,
we wanted to make sure we were
a little bit more laser-focused.
So we realize the
only engagement metric
that really mattered
was, if they do it,
do they stay longer?
We need that correlation
between longer tenure for us
to be willing to
spend air time trying
to get anyone to do something.
And a couple of
things really popped.
So newsletter sign-ups, if you
have a group of new subscribers
who sign up for a
newsletter compared
to a group of subscribers
who don't, nine months later,
you'll have 15% more of
them if they did that.
And obviously on
the usage of the app
in addition to the website is
an even more surprising number.
So now we've kind of got our
compass points ready to go.
So one thing that's
interesting is
that 80% of our orders on
wsj.com come on desktop.
The conversion rate
is so much higher.
Actually the traffic
ratio is much more even,
but the end result is
much higher on desktop
because the conversion rate
just is significantly higher up.
So how do you get someone
on a desktop computer
to download an app and
to know that they did it?
Now the Android
store, the Play Store,
does have a good
solution around this.
The iOS store doesn't.
Our users tend to
skew a little bit more
on the iOS side of things.
So we've got this problem
where we figured out
the one thing we want
them to do desperately,
and for 80% of them, we'll never
really know if they did it.
So you've got this sort
of connection problem.
So all we did is we
added a little link text.
There's this little link
texting functionality.
It's silly, silly stuff.
Enter your cell phone number.
It immediately-- we
don't keep the number.
We immediately delete it.
We send you a text which
senses whether you've
got an iOS or an Android
device and sends you
a link to the appropriate app.
That was a 95% lift in app
downloads on onboarding.
Absolutely nuts.
Just again, just trying
to approach things
in a very, very simple way.
The next thing we did with our
onboarding was our onboarding
historically was a single
sort of static page.
And we realized they just
came from a checkout, which
is mandatory obviously,
and card-based.
So we wondered, could we
psychologically leverage
this experience going
into onboarding where
the stuff that we really
would love to do--
and we know they're going to
value our product a lot more.
They're going to get much more
out of it if they actually
do perform these actions.
So we wondered if we could
leverage that experience
once we got to onboarding.
So we turned onboarding into
a card-based experience.
So the most important
thing it does
is it focused them in on
one experience at a time.
So their attention
was not divided
between the four things.
And we obviously were able
to prioritize them in order
of benefit to them and to us.
But the second thing is just
because it looked card-based
and it looked like the checkout,
it just felt just mandatory
enough, even though there's a
very large skip and continue
button on any of them, that
we were able to really get
really--
dramatically increase
the rate at which
they're doing all these
things, which just enhances
the value of the subscription
they just decided to purchase.
And I think that's
about all I got.
[APPLAUSE]